I mean on my pants.
- Oh, look at her pants.
- We can essentially rap
your leggings if you want.
- Perfect.
- Is that okay?
You don't mind if my lovely camera man-
- Yeah, we give our consent.
- Is-
- Okay, it's gonna seem pervy.
- I'm so excited, Carly.
- Carly, I'm Chris, a
pleasure to meet you.
Let's drop this and let's
rap about Carly's leggings.
- All right.
(hip hop beat playing)
Okay.
♪ Flow off the head ♪
♪ Off the dome ♪
♪ It's kinda weird that I
ever rap about clothes ♪
♪ And admittedly, we gonna aim below ♪
♪ We gonna ignore the
parka like a rainbow ♪
♪ So many colors ♪
♪ Yeah we checked them ♪
♪ Carly respecting ♪
♪ Rockin' the spectrum ♪
♪ Lookin' like Isaac Newton in a suit ♪
♪ Anyway down to the leggings ♪
♪ Oh shoot ♪
♪ Startin' with the mountain ♪
♪ Here we go ♪
♪ From the top down low ♪
♪ It be topped with snow ♪
♪ You've got a little thing ♪
♪ I'm never going to settle ♪
♪ When I'm on Everest
I'm testin' my mettle ♪
♪ To the right ♪
♪ Yeah, I get this a lot ♪
♪ We got sticks around
a little, little fox ♪
♪ You gotta come down here,
Chris so you can see ♪
♪ Bring it in closer here with me ♪
♪ I know it's really
pervy for us to zoom in ♪
♪ But we got a little
fir tree I'm assuming ♪
♪ This one ♪
♪ Oh yes, right there ♪
♪ Covering the hair it's
a little black bear ♪
♪ White nose, gonna hunt down the honey ♪
♪ Volkswagen Beetle it's
right on the money ♪
♪ I'm not being funny ♪
♪ I would be a champion ♪
♪ If I had one of these,
I would go camping. ♪
♪ Like you, it's called the Type 2 ♪
♪ Here's a little outline ♪
♪ Yeah I try to ♪
♪ Go to the lake ♪
♪ That's my wish ♪
♪ I'm gonna go right in,
gonna catch the fish ♪
♪ But over here, yeah
I got a master plan ♪
♪ We got a tent, then we got a
little wigwam and a caravan ♪
♪ Looking like an Airstream ♪
♪ I'm really kind of weirded out ♪
♪ If I was a teenage boy,
I'd be gettin' so aroused ♪
♪ And over here got a
very cute little owl ♪
♪ With the white wings ♪
♪ Oh yes, Carly ♪
♪ Let me go down where your toenails be ♪
♪ Tiny little sun, lookin' like a donut ♪
♪ And a little bit of purple ♪
♪ Yeah don't it ♪
♪ Rhyme with anything I don't know ♪
♪ But that's a freestyle
rap from head to toe ♪
- (screams) Yes! (clapping)
Chris, I love it.
- Carly,
thank you very much for
letting us rap about your
undercarriage.
I should apologize to my wife immediately.
- Yeah, it's like, uh,
it's all happening right here.
- You are?
- Elizabeth.
- Elizabeth, hi and?
- Matt
- You met in?
- Denver.
- Running Club.
Okay, cool.
Long distance, short distance.
- I'm short distance, he runs 100 miles.
- What mate! How?
What do you do
or what did you do before
the world collapsed?
(Matt laughs)
- I work in accounting
and he is transitioning from accounting
and now he's doing
mental health counseling.
- Amazing.
I can't make jokes about that-
(Matt laughs)
but that's great.
And where are you getting married?
- At the top of the mountain.
- Mount Crested Butte
- The ski area.
- Yeah, on the ski area.
- That's amazing. Amazing.
Okay. I'm going to drop a beat.
Don't worry by the way,
this won't be as bad as
you think it's going to be.
(both chuckle)
♪ A nice long bit of white dress ♪
♪ A beautiful pair, it's
Matt and 'Lizabeth ♪
♪ Both of them, a perfect match ♪
♪ Height, corsage ♪
♪ I'm not being slight ♪
♪ I'm just saying Matt's not large ♪
♪ But he runs large distances ♪
♪ He sees a hundred miles ♪
♪ He's like, "This is it" ♪
♪ One step at a time ♪
♪ From the start to the finish ♪
♪ Line, when it comes
to accounting admit it ♪
♪ You're the best there is ♪
♪ Out of the red and in the black ♪
♪ Or the other way round that I said ♪
♪ Maybe double entry
when it's in the ledger ♪
♪ Better than Scrooge
or Marley and I bet ya ♪
♪ Transitioning, make less wealth ♪
♪ But more happy in yourself ♪
♪ With the mental health ♪
♪ You do all the stuff
that's needed to succeed ♪
♪ People won't commit suicide or bleed ♪
♪ I know it's slightly dark ♪
♪ We don't need that ♪
♪ But where are you marrying ♪
♪ Wow, top like a hat ♪
♪ Mount Crested Butte ♪
♪ You'll both be looking so cute ♪
♪ Presumably in this lovely
dress and this suit ♪
♪ Over there on the top,
right above the clouds ♪
♪ Put the ring on your finger ♪
♪ Stand there so proud ♪
♪ Wearing a tiara, wearing a mask ♪
♪ There we go, a freestyle rap ♪
♪ For 'Lizabeth and Matt ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
(cheers)
You're welcome.
Get some things out you
want me to rap about
and I will then rap about them for you.
I hope you're enjoying the video.
Make sure you hit that like
button and I will release
another episode of me
rapping in Crested Butte.
That's good to know.
Amazing. And what have you got?
(laughing)
(muffled speaking)
- Oh, this is good.
(laughing)
This is good.
(beep)
- Okay, great. Perfect. That's good.
Let's do this. Yeah.
♪ I drop the rhymes and they scream ♪
♪ Coming from Hawaii, Aloha, sun screen ♪
♪ 30 SPF, nothing better than that ♪
♪ Although 50 and maybe a wide straw hat ♪
♪ Keep the sun off your head ♪
♪ You've got the blonde locks ♪
♪ And inhaler in case you choke a lot ♪
♪ Your lungs fail you ♪
♪ You need to get it there in ♪
♪ And puff, puff, ProAir Ventolin ♪
♪ I take care of my
lungs, my bronchioles ♪
♪ And also my teeth outside my oral hole ♪
♪ That's a bit of floss ♪
♪ Keep it in your bag ♪
♪ So if you have a kind
of midnight snack ♪
♪ You can take out the little bits ♪
♪ Cleanse of the plaque ♪
♪ Purell, soothing gel,
don't take it back ♪
♪ You need that ♪
♪ People jacking up the prices ♪
♪ Because coronavirus advice is ♪
♪ You're like this ♪
♪ You gotta cleanse your hands ♪
♪ Now hold it out of your jeans ♪
♪ Yeah, we understand. ♪
♪ We know what you got ♪
♪ Okay, we succeed ♪
♪ He doesn't want anyone to say ♪
♪ But it's... ♪
♪ Well, illegal drugs in some countries ♪
♪ But over here, it's fine ♪
♪ It's free, grows on trees ♪
♪ You can get that ♪
♪ And let me say crack a smile ♪
♪ If you lose your wallet ♪
♪ You can track it with a Tile ♪
♪ That's God's honest truth ♪
♪ You use the Bluetooth ♪
♪ And here's a little thing
that will loosen your tooth ♪
♪ You put it on your gums ♪
♪ The nicotine pouch ♪
♪ Means that it falls out of your mouth ♪
♪ Did you know this was a real danger ♪
♪ Of ingesting cool mint ♪
♪ No stranger, gives you fresh breath ♪
♪ And gives you all the buzz ♪
♪ But actually will kill you one day ♪
♪ Sorry, cuz ♪
(crowd cheers)
There we go
- Good job dude.
- Thank you very much.
- That was good man.
- Thank you,
I'm glad you liked it.
What would you like a rap about?
Anything at all.
- Let's do ladybugs.
- Ladybugs. Okay.
In Britain, ladybirds, we call them.
Isn't that weird?
They are not birds...
So yeah, I know. We're stupid.
We invented the language
though, so calm down.
Um, so ladybugs?
- I was inspired by her tie dye.
- Tie dye? Great.
- Paganism.
- Paganism, cool.
Okay. Yeah, exactly.
I'm gonna drop a little beat for you guys.
♪ Ask me questions, when
push comes to shove ♪
♪ My favorite insect of
course, the ladybug ♪
♪ Fly away home. Your house ablaze ♪
♪ That is arson ♪
♪ I see a ladybug, I pass one. ♪
♪ Awesome ♪
♪ I bend down, I pick it up a lot ♪
♪ I kiss it on its back ♪
♪ Love their little black spots ♪
♪ Count the number, usually even ♪
♪ But sometimes they're
yellow for no reason ♪
♪ It's treason, committed
like I slander the queen ♪
♪ Tie dye, if I was a hippie I'm keen ♪
♪ I take all of my pale clothes ♪
♪ And dip it in a usual bowl for washing ♪
♪ I begin with the thick dye ♪
♪ This is how I feel ♪
♪ In the past they crushed beetles ♪
♪ And used Cochineal ♪
♪ That's a true fact ♪
♪ Yeah, light through a prism ♪
♪ I shatter all the
preconception paganism ♪
♪ Real good man, let me say to you ♪
♪ We need Christmas ♪
♪ It's coming from Saturnalia ♪
♪ All the Christian religions did a lot ♪
♪ But then this one's more recent ♪
♪ We can call it Vinotok ♪
♪ Drip drop. I'm getting
drunk off the barley wine ♪
♪ I love the pagan time ♪
♪ In the summertime and fall ♪
♪ That's a type of harvest festival ♪
♪ We burn all of the
priests and best of all ♪
♪ The witches rise again with
their little black cats ♪
♪ But no more noir, a tie dye hat ♪
♪ Is what they like to use ♪
♪ They put it on their dome ♪
♪ And then they ride a broomstick
with the kitten back home ♪
There you go
(crowd cheers)
(pants) Thank you.
It's even harder at eight
and a half thousand feet
with a mask in your face.
Do you guys have like things on you?
Like objects?
- Well I went to the bathroom-
- Oh no.
- Oh here we go
(group chattering)
- And in the woods, and...
- Okay, great.
So slides, a used tampon from the woods.
That's amazing and you're responsible.
You didn't just bury it.
- I didn't.
- Napkins I stole from the restaurant?
- Napkins you stole from the restaurant.
- And a bike lock key?
- And bike lock key.
Okay, cool.
Well, let's, let's rap about this.
This is all made up by the way.
It's all freestyle.
♪ You took it without asking ♪
♪ You thieve it there ♪
♪ From the restaurant, the napkins ♪
♪ You thought, "Yeah, greasy
fingers, give a try" ♪
♪ How thick are they? ♪
♪ Maybe three ply ♪
♪ Why spend money? ♪
♪ Yes. Y'all just go to McDonald's ♪
♪ Your local food hall ♪
♪ Take a little bit of the paper ♪
♪ No need for all the kitchen roll ♪
♪ Let me talk about this ♪
♪ What's your goal? ♪
♪ That your bike don't get stole ♪
♪ Don't risk these ♪
♪ A karabiner with a
set of bike lock keys ♪
♪ Please keep it locked
up safe and sound ♪
♪ While the spokes on the
wheels go round and round ♪
♪ And this, in your arms ♪
♪ Hands, you handle ♪
♪ Got a pair of the slides and
the socks with the sandals ♪
♪ What do your socks say? ♪
♪ Here we go ♪
♪ There's a little hole ♪
♪ 'Qloom' with the toe ♪
♪ I like the color you
put inside the thing ♪
♪ It protects your feet ♪
♪ When you're striding and walking ♪
♪ When you're in the Crested town ♪
♪ You need to make sure
you turn the cotton brown ♪
♪ Or maybe red ♪
♪ When push comes to shove ♪
♪ You've got to keep the cotton
at the time of the month ♪
♪ Every 28 days, it's really vital ♪
♪ You line up, menstruate,
that's the cycle ♪
♪ Coming to the moon ♪
♪ Bring a little zip lock ♪
♪ Got that time again
wristwatch tick tock ♪
♪ In the woods, gonna take a risk ♪
♪ Crouching down, people walking
past: "Are you pissing?" ♪
♪ No! I'm just removing the string. ♪
♪ Put it in the napkin. You were asking ♪
♪ Can I borrow these ♪
♪ Don't leave it by the trees ♪
♪ A used tampon in a rap ♪
Good geez!
There you go.
(crowd cheers)
Thank you very much, guys.
It was a pleasure rapping for you.
Have a lovely evening.
Cheers guys. Thank you.
Thank you for watching guys.
Make sure you like, comment, subscribe
and I will see you next time
for another episode of me
rapping in Crested Butte.